oh
eh bien bon soir des gones à l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs avec une
très grande actualité cette semaine et
je reçois josé de sousa rebond soir josé
bonsoir stefan savage osez vous mettrais
bien bon soir chez l'internaute
alors moi je voudrais revenir avant de
concevoir des vies dans cette actualité
qui est très chaude et je crois qu'on
est gâtés depuis le mois de janvier
puisque l'actualité n'arrête pas d'être
importante
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur ta
prestation de la semaine dernière où tu
vas interviewé le numéro un français
joie de lautier ah bah oui c'était un
grand moment et c'était bon une star
toujours les échecs une star une star
mondiale meilleur joueur du monde et il
a été champion du monde junior il a
battu kasparov il a battu karpov il a
battu les meilleurs joueurs du monde et
il est positif comme casse parents et
évolutif c'est l'un des rares joueurs au
monde qui sur dix partis je crois qu'il
mène cinq et demi à quatre et demi donc
trois victoires avec deux en fait
d'ailleurs il y avait un autre français
à maman qui était positif c'est est-ce
parce qu'ils m'ont mais de finhan mais
les français réussissent bien montre
contre kasparov
c'était un grand moment sur et surtout
dès le début il y avait une espèce
d'intensité bon qu'on va manger demander
s'il veut toujours être champion du
monde
j'étais surpris par la réponse s'il
était amené oui à mon sa tête pas vu mon
parce que donc un oui france franc et
massif
il veut être champion du monde alors
c'est vrai que la nouvelle formule
avantage puisque bon là on voit que
khalifa et des champions du monde
pourquoi pas lautié mais je pense que
même s'ils avaient été l'ancien système
il aurait dit oui aussi d'ailleurs idem
les matches il aime le combat
ouais je crois que c'est les invite
d'ailleurs alors voir si vous l'avez pas
vu ou le voir voilà l'avantagé des gones
a évidemment c'est que vous pouvez
revoir toutes les émissions passées
depuis la première édile
première émission en décembre 98
donc ça fait plus de plus de 65
programme je crois à peu près qui sont
visionnables dont celui de la semaine
dernière donc avec pour la première fois
ceux des bonal joël lautier
voilà donc on en est revenu sur cette
interview donc je vous invite tous les
deux à revoir cette interview de joie de
lautier par josé de sousa la semaine
dernière et nous allons maintenant
passer josé à l'actualité de cette
semaine nous l'avions annoncé un petit
peu la semaine dernière mais ça chauffe
drôlement et ça chauffe surtout à cannes
alors on a déjà beaucoup parlé des
matches à cannes cannes c'est une ville
où il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
faites on en avait parlé des matches
chaque chef donc contre contre david
eckstein avait parlé donc furent voit
lancer une émission à ce moment là
également et aujourd'hui une nouvelle
formule puisque match comme dans les
tournois finalement une pièce jointe et
nice n'ont peut-être pas dû rappeler la
formule d'ailleurs oui on peut rappeler
à prendre rapidement parce qu'on va
avoir
vers 21h30 et warhol anges qui est à
cannes pour nous c'est en exclusivité
qui a participé à ce tournoi et qui
aussi suit le match
qui est à côté du master's donc le
masters ce sont des matchs par
élimination il y avait 32 jours je crois
au départ et c'est des matches en deux
parties par élimination et en cas
d'égalité il ya des blitz de départage
et à ce jeu là c'est la 10h04 chef josé
qui a gagné la 19,4 chef qui va
retrouver le haut niveau à bordeaux
puisqu'il va rencontrer au grand prix de
bordeaux ce fameux grand prix
début avril donc le vainqueur du masters
de cannes va pouvoir rencontrer le
numéro 7 mondial mais que la dame est le
numéro un français je vois le lotier
ainsi que le vice champion du monde
actuel de dkd laurent frayssinet donc
c'est une confirmation du nom de
vladislav tkachiev qui a pris le gain de
ces deux matchs organisés contre david
et contre le hollandais j'ai oublié de
van der wiel voilà le boucher aux
landais
confirme sa très bonne forme actuelle et
sa progression est actuellement numéro 1
mondial et il approche ils approchent à
grands pas de la 10e place mondiale et
donc du top mondial absolu celui où où
on peut être invité dans le plus grand
tournoi du monde
et d'ailleurs je dois te féliciter
puisque tu as le nez de choisir des
joueurs qui sont au coeur de l'actualité
en ce moment donc je les félicite
puisque tu es chef bon on va voir
d'ailleurs ce qu'il fait en dehors de
son fief parce que bon maintenant il est
cannois et en tout ce qui est local y
gagne on va voir si à bordeaux il veut
faire aussi bien mais c'est un
concurrent dangereux pour les pour l'éco
pour le tirer et puis pour impressionner
voilà donc dans ce master on peut noter
aussi la très bonne performance de notre
chroniqueur habituel nicolas giffard
mais si que fait qu'à passer je crois
trois tours deux ou trois tourtes avait
jusqu'en quarts de finale
bon alors il est éliminé mais lui c'est
un joueur au tennis aussi même il aime
ce cette formule unis nation direct et
on joue sans compromis et puis bon il y
en a qui passent voilà un autre notre
écrivain favori puisque c'est a priori
maintenant son métier plus tôt
de prédilection écrivain continue à
avoir un très très bon niveau de
compétition aux échecs et il l'a prouvé
à cannes encore une fois et on va on va
arrêter là pour le descriptif de master
parce qu'elle est au volant je m'en veux
dire à plus mais alors à cannes dont qui
se passe actuellement aussi un joli
match qui est entre notre star jeunes
entre guillemets montante etienne bacrot
celui qui est à la poursuite de joël
lautier actuellement pour essayer de
ravir sa place de numéro 1 français
contre donc là lyon la légende vivante
actuelle des échecs
parmi d'autres évidemment mais peut-être
la plus encore le joueur le plus fort en
activité anatoly karpov donc champion du
monde pendant des années de 1975 à 1985
et puis tout récemment aussi puisqu'il
avait reconquis son titre donc
anatoly karpov rencontre etienne bacrot
avec donc si rapsi partie par dans trois
cas danses différentes
oui je pense que donc c'est vraiment un
vrai challenge et maintenant peut être
un petit avantage à bacrot parce qu'il a
réussi dans les deux premières parties à
faire match nul sur les pertinentes
donc pourquoi pas espérer puis un peut
être le cardié penser à la chance de
bach rouge elle peut lui sourire alors
ce que disent ils tiennent c'est que
comme karpov reste extrêmement fort en
partie très rapide puisqu'il a fait un
excellent champlain du monde de blitz
offert au tournoi mondial de blitz en
fait je ne sais pas trop comment
l'appeler mais il ya en pologne et bien
donc un très très grand tournoi de blitz
et karpov est arrivé dans les tous
premiers il reste plus fort encore
karpov dans les parties rapides grâce à
son extrême expérience et son intuition
phénoménal puisque dans les parties
rapides c'est ça qui prime
plutôt que le calcul puisque on n'a pas
le temps de tout bois oui vous faites
voilà en fait dans les parties très
rapide c'est un bon avantage pour lui
puisque bon il est un jour très intuitif
et dans les parties très longue aussi
puisque là il a le temps de calcul et de
poser son jeu mais mon petit revenir
mais dans la première partie du match
j'étais impressionné je pense au caire
pour fêter un peu moins bien et dans
cette note il a retourné la situation et
à la fin peut-être même bon il avait des
petites chansons s'est soldé par un nul
et je pense qu'en jeu très rapide où
l'instinct comme ça il est très fort
c'est vrai donc on va voir ce qu'il
advienne ce match pour l'instant un
partout après les parties l'homme il est
resté deux parties semi-rapides qu'on
appelle semi-rapide josé donc avec 25
minutes par jour je pourrai à peu près
c'est ça justement et ensuite des
politiques blitz il y aura deux blitz e
finaux disons ne départage entre
guillemets on fait un film on est je
crois que le match aller sur six parties
aux vainqueurs des six mais avec cette
curiosité inhabituel où il ya trois
cadence différentes
je pense que c'est difficile à gérer
pour les joueurs et mais bon si on peut
faire apparaître avec le tennis là
c'était karpov qui servait bon il ya eu
match nul maintenant ces bacs croquis
serge parce que on s'y met rapide on l'a
vu contre polgar il a gagné le match
quand même et là il ya le calcul qui
priment aussi et après les beats
peut-être avantage à karpov mes espions
cubains crossmed à l'abri mois on verra
en tout cas en commentera cette victoire
7 défaites la semaine prochaine
évidemment je me suis donc ça on se
marre bien sûr exactement il peut très
bien avoir ma chance je sais pas s'il
avait prévu des parties de départage en
cas de machines à ressasser me pose une
colle je sais pas trop voilà donc cette
actualité il focalise à cannes et pas
uniquement il ya aussi le tournoi le
fameux tournant de cappelle-la-grande
dont on parle un peu moins d'habitude
effectivement mais qui s'imposent année
après année quand même très grand
tournoi mondial surtout par la présence
des joueurs titrés
il ya beaucoup de grands maîtres et
beaucoup de m eur toi tu connais bien ce
tournoi josé suis pas me parler en mieux
comment donc je les fais une fois mais
c'est vrai que c'est un temps qui peu
médiatisé mais alors bon l'organisation
jeu
donc c'est la femme de larbitre une
ampleur qui parle russe et donc qui a
tissé un réseau disons aleph est
beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs des pays de
l'est viennent beaucoup de jours titre
et c'est cette fois un phénoménal même
là les toits de linares de linares ubeda
qui sont considérés comme très fort à
côté c'est rien quoi parce que là
vraiment donc là c'est pas un tournoi
fermé cependant open sur tout le monde
peut venir jouer
il ya donc je sais plus communes
participantes monsieur aux alentours de
400 banques plus solides avec les 2 400
500 mais surtout c'est plus de 100
grands maîtres et plus de 60 mètres ben
je crois en quelque chose que c'est
phénoménal et puis il ya dans les rues
si à tous ceux qui tout ce qui monte et
tous ceux qui sont déjà présents il ya
gourévitch par exemple bonjour très
établi les joueurs d'expérience mais il
ya aussi les petits jeunes russes qu'on
va voir dans quelques années et qui vont
avoir de 1600 parce que comme ils font
plaisir d'invitation series invite tous
les joueurs dit raymond ça permet à peu
de frais dillon de venir en europe
voilà donc on parlera aussi évidemment
de ce résultat du tournoi de
cappelle-la-grande qui est donc un must
et qui est en france et d'ailleurs tu
dois aussi signé de la formule c'est que
c'est une formule assez compliqué
d'appariement puisque en fonction de sa
force on a déjà des poings fictif à au
début et donc il n'y a pas cette ce
fameux fort faible quand on joue un
tournoi traditionnel au début et que
vous êtes faibles ont fait tout le temps
un fort et qu'on est de forme de tout le
temps un faible et là les écarts sont
réduits de force disons que voilà et
après ça s'équilibre au bout de deux à
trois rondes mais
des adversaires de son niveau ce qui est
intéressant pour tout le monde pour les
joueurs débutants et que je montre des
choses de leur force et donc progresser
marquer des points
et pareil pour pour l'effort joueurs qui
jouent entre eux donc ça s'appellera tu
peux nous rappeler que si je crois c'est
près de lille ouais c'est près de
dunkerque en fait d'un quart à la
dunkerque
voilà donc en dehors de la france cher
arnaud d'une heure voilà donc on va
venir tout de suite à notre parti
commentés dû jour on va essayer d'y
passer pas mal de temps parce qu'il est
très intéressante donc du masters de
cannes c'était je crois la demi finale
les demi-finales de josé entre anatolie
va y sert qu'un spécialiste mondial du
jeu rapide et donc wladys faire quatre
chefs le futur vainqueur
c'était la deuxième partie du match
donc anatolie weisser à l'eiblen il doit
l'emporter contre eux vladislav quatre
chefs
voilà donc pour suivre cette partie avec
nous évidemment vous pourrez la suivre
sur la vidéo vous allez voir l'échiquier
et donc les possibilités de flèches et
de et de cases allumé et de commentaires
évidemment en est que josé de sousa mais
vous avez aussi la deuxième possibilité
en cliquant sur l'icône jouer contre
jose sucre aux crises
je crois que alors comme n'est ni gare
sert à canal web ce soir il ya beaucoup
de bonne humeur et je crois que dans la
régie ça rigole pas mal
donc vous pouvez cliquer sur l'icône
jouer pour suivre la partie avec nous ou
alors cliquer sur l'icône pgm pour
télécharger le fichier p g n et le lire
avec un logiciel logiciels que nous vous
proposons par exemple donc dans notre
partie différée de diagonale il ya des
logiciels disponibles pour donc lire ces
parties voilà donc plusieurs façons avec
une pompe pour vous de suivre cette
partie avec nous on va commencer tout de
suite avec la position initiale de cette
partie entre donc anatolie valserres
champion de france 1997 contre donc vers
10 kva quatre chefs qui est maintenant
vie en france d'origine du case as tu
casses et kazakh en fait du kazakhstan
d'origine kazakhe russes aussi leur
usine à la fois kazakhe russe en fait et
qui qui parle très bien notamment le
français d'ailleurs et quitte donc
installé en france voilà fait quelques
interviews d'ailleurs deux chefs en
français parfait tout à fait donc une
interview que le transit des échecs
français voilà le temps des échecs
français on vous invite à le revoir dans
les émissions du mois de février je
crois me févry 99 2
diagonal une émission sur le tournoi
d'enghien les bains où vous pourrez
retrouver une interview de vladislav
quatre chefs
voilà donc on va démarrer tout de suite
josé avec les premiers coups qu'on va
pas trop commenter puisque ont alors
peut-être déjà dès le deuxième coulée
noire
après donc les coups des quatre des cinq
c4 les noirs choisissent de prendre le
pion c4 est souvent le noir refuse et
donc ils ces deux ouvertures différentes
qui sont jouables toutes les deux mais
en fait oui là donc là c'était le gambit
de la dame on a vu une corse et d4 d5 le
coût des quatre des cinq c4
c'est le gambit de la dame et là on dit
c'est le gambit la dame accepté c'est à
dire finalement les noirs offre le pion
donc je sais pas si tu peux le montrer
que les noix accepte le pion qui a été
offert donc là maintenant les voir
virtuellement un pion de plus donc il ya
deux méthodes pour les noirs soient
renforcées le centre soit finalement
laissé le centre blanc puis l'attaqué
donc donc là ils ont choisi de laisser
le centre puisque maintenant les blancs
se retrouve avec deux pions contre un
seul pour les noirs donc un petit
avantage au centre mais bon pour
l'instant pour le prix d'une pure mais
on va voir que les blancs le récupère
très vite en fait oui et puis le jeu ça
va être le centre blanc contre la contre
attaque mois donc on va voir donc les
blancs continuent avec le coup trois ans
tout de suite on voit ainsi que l'idée
simple un double ouverture c'est que le
fou ici va pouvoir reprendre le pion et
il n'y a pas trop de moyens de défendre
ses opinions si ce n'est au prix de
grands risques et de grands de grands
de désillusions gagnant ne s'est pas ce
pas le but de la stratégie des noirs des
très jeunes noirs c'est de laisser le
centre blanc s'établir et puis le contre
attaquer donc donc les noirs choisi de
ne pas défendre
effectivement le pian et le coup trois
cavaliers m6 les bleus en quatrième coup
prennent le pion avec fou prend ces
quatre là les noirs continuent un coup
logique aussi qui est de jouer le coup
ici commune voire du plan en six
l'avantagé c'est que sa bouche
la diagonale ici du fou est par contre
le désavantage aussi on peut citer c'est
que ce fou ans et 8 ici est bloqué par
son propre pions donc il va falloir
trouver des opportunités pour ce fou à
terme
ah oui d'ailleurs le jeu des blancs
c'était une petite finesse justement
pour enfermer ce fou mais faut noter que
le foot des blancs en c1 aussi est
enfermé voilà aussi ce fou ici but
contre son propre pions en e3 le phocéen
effectivement il est aussi enfermé donc
les avantages et les inconvénients des
deux côtés voilà cinq cavaliers trois
ans sur les pièces écologique et là ça y
est tout de suite voilà déjà on peut
commenter ce coup jose au cinquième
coulée noire joue un coup on en a parlé
souvent le coup c5 qui crée une tension
centrale entre le plan de 6,5 et le pion
de l'es4 voile alors les tout le jeu se
base au centre un donc les cases
donc là c'est la caisse des cats mais la
case de 4 la case de 5 la casse des cinq
donc ça apparaît souvent donc pour
montrer les quatre centrales
effectivement ici tout se joue est lui
tout seul je ressens donc tous les coups
des blancs tous les coups des noirs si
vous reprenez la partie très lentement
vous allez voir sont dirigées contre ces
cases d'accord les 15,4 des 4 5 et d5
est ici les blancs ont pris le centre
parce qu'ils sont comme stéphane tu le
disais les deux pions centraux vont être
contraints et maintenant finalement les
noirs contre attaque contre attaque est
donc confiante de l'ale ce pion femmes
pioncer 5 en positionner en rouge ici et
c'est de s'échanger contre le bus notre
halle de façon équilibrée le sens le
débat
alors petit robe pour les blancs donc
logique on sur les pièces et en rock le
plus rapidement possible soit aussi
encore des bons c'est des schémas
généraux bon évidemment il ya un certain
ordre joël lautier a été beaucoup plus
précis la semaine dernière puisqu'il a
dit avant sur en méfiez vous des schémas
généraux aussi mais bon ils ont que de
façon générale on peut dire que c'est le
rock ici l'un étant quand même beaucoup
mais il d'ailleurs lui c'est un
spécialiste de vente là avec les noirs
donc il y aura été d'une grande utilité
aujourd'hui encore mais malheureusement
là les noirs jouent le coup à six alors
le coup ici pendant je vais montrer en
rouge le coup ici deux pions en a six au
6e coup pour les noirs al'avantage de
pouvoir essayer de faire la poussée
bessette enlevé cinq
voilà pour le noir je montrais en rouge
et 7 pouces et b5 attaquerait le fou
évidemment en c4 et permettrait aux
noirs de positionner le fou s'est vite
sur la case bessette obtenant une très
grande diagonale intéressante donc c'est
le principal je pense c'est la
principale idée de ce coût à 7 à 6 mais
en fait la légende et blanc ont fait on
fait de coupes cirque avant il attaqué
pas le centre maintenant les noirs aussi
essaye de jouer à 6 et puis de jeu de
mail y auraient leur position est aussi
il faut mentionner que la caisse b5
aussi va être protégé c'est aussi une
autre idée c'est à dire pour éviter que
par exemple des cinq sets cas ce que je
vous montre en
r alors je peux le montré aussi en
jambes voilà la case n 5 est protégé
disons c'est un coup aussi qui menacent
de jouer est ce que tu veux dire
bessette b 5 mai et de protéger la case
de 5 également
alors voyons la suite les blancs
continuent avec le coup à 4 justement ça
empêche avec ce coup à quatre ça empêche
bessette b5 puisque ça se rencontrer
immédiatement par la prise en d5 donc ce
qu à quatre en fait typiquement contre
l'idée des noirs de ces de ne prendre de
l'espace à la dame oui en plus les bleus
auraient pu aussi je pense que possible
tous les coups la six ont déjà été joués
reprenant cette position c'est vraiment
une position classique weiser lui c'est
un spécialiste journaux position est ce
un jour très classique c'est un russe
qui a quand même une quarantaine
d'années c'est la vieille école russe il
est trés il connaît bien les principes
échec 1-1 et à cette position il a
domine d'une pas mal est là il va
empêcher il vexé empêcher l'expansion
elle n'a alors les noirs continuent donc
par le couple et ses six ils vont rester
pour l'instant avec le problème de ce
fou c'est 8 1 qu'il faudra il faudra
qu'il trouve une case ainsi vient 17
c'est pas tellement un super à venir
pour lui parce qu'il sera il faut en
rien de plus et il faudrait qu'ils
viennent sur cette case is it bessette
avec une jolie action ici sur cd banal
mais pour l'instant c'est pas facile
puisque les blancs empêcher le plan b
c'est de b5 et donc il nous faut
retrouver peut-être autre chose
alors en attendant de trouver cette
solution les blancs continuent leur
développement avec le coup ici dans me2
donc au huitième coup les blancs mettre
leurs dames sur la case 2 avec l'idée
josé c'est que si les noirs échanges au
centre ici sur la case des quatre les
blancs pourrait reprendre avec le pion
de 3 est libérée
l'action de la dame sur cette colonne et
ça permettrait peut-être à 7 tours après
devenir cette case d1 en semences une
possibilité de leko perez dame le pion
isolé de la dame
c'est très dangereux pour les noirs et
il va isère en plus est un spécialiste
sur l'opposition c'est à dire que les
noirs vont
les blancs vont avoir une faiblesse
statique très difficile à protéger le
plan des cats
mais en échange ils vont avoir une
domination des casses centrale qui va
les aider dans leurs attaques
donc tu as mentionné une colonne ouverte
sur le roi et est donc c'est un jeu à
double tranchant les noirs aussi de
tenir et pour s est joué la finale par
exemple et les blancs dans ces jo
dynamique note qui si les blancs les
noirs pourrait gagner un pur mais avec
des effets très dangereux il pourrait
prendre l'option des quatre simplement
le premier quand même peut-être les
blancs pour le clou et se baladent
selectour des uns et le récupérer
ensuite le segment avec de grosses
menaces
donc il faut faire attention pour et
noir ne pas essayer de gagner trop de
matériel tant que le rouennais surtout
na par ok ils se demandent donc ils
jouent donc là au 8e coulée noire
effectivement joué le coup dams et 7 un
coût de développement aussi on s'enlève
de 7,2 cette colonne qui peut être
dangereuse maintenant qu'une tour
blanche pour y être et la dame
finalement il pas si mal placé cola elle
contrôle
elle peut contrôler cette colonne est
aussi avoir des visées éventuelles sur
le roi noir sur le râble ans par donc
jusqu'à la case h 2 donc ça peut être
très intéressant et surtout à noter que
justement chaque chef connaît le style
de 20 heures il sait qu'il est un très
bon attaquant et donc ils empêchent ils
refusent de rentrer dans un pion isolé
voilà donc quatre chefs qui a les noirs
ils refusent de rendre présent ce que
connaît bien meiser et en plus
l'avantagé de ne pas prendre au centre
c'est que le fout des blancs sur la
casse c'est un ici est toujours bouché
par son pion 3 alors que si on échange
avec les noirs on va se retrouver avec
un fou c'est l'homme qui va jaillir
probablement sur la case g5 sur cette
quasi si près du cavalier 1 qui créera
des menaces dangereuses alors à noter
quand même que ce n'est pas un mauvais
coup de rentrer de l'isoler c'est à dire
c'est une autre stratégie c'est la
possibilité pour la le dynamic control
est statique il ya une faiblesse mais en
échange on laisse les blancs attaquer
donc là ce qui joue donc josé en fait
c'est surtout la psychologie 1 les
possibilités existent on peut prendre en
d4
on peut choisir de ne pas reprendre il
se trouve que à la taulière connaît très
bien la position qui résultent de
échangeant des quatre îles vanille
savent quatre chefs le sait donc évite
cette position sur il essaie de jouer
des positions qui connaît
e et connais moi mes adversaires à noter
aussi que comme il mène la première
partie il va pas prendre de risque
inutile de jouer un jeu sauvage voilà il
lui suffit de faire une nulle aussi pour
rassurer la victoire et la sage en
finale c'est pour ça que ces matchs sont
passionnants parce que il ya un peu de
psychologie derrière voici donc alors on
va voir maintenant le coup fawcett pour
les noirs donc elles font ils ont joué
vous qu'ils seront là les blancs jouent
b3 alors là justement au 10e coup alors
l'idée maintenant c'est qu'effectivement
comme le fond blanc alors on dit enfin
je pense que c'est la deuxième partie
une fête jeu on n'a pas vérifié on n'est
pas suivi
on n'est pas certain que ce soit la
deuxième partie du match c'est peut-être
la première à l'europe mais moi je pense
que c'est la deuxième mais bon faudrait
faudra vérifier après malheureusement
n'a pas d'adversaire voilà c'est
l'anniversaire n'a plus le temps de
vérifier en fait c'est pas grave peu
importe ici les blancs jouent le coup b3
l'idée c'est simplement que ce fou
maintenant on va pouvoir sortir par
exemple sur la case à 3 ou sur la case
b2 étant donné qu'il est bouché ici sur
la cause du pur en trois comme les noirs
ont pas choisi de prendre il faut
trouver de l'air se fout donc c'est une
logique finalement et puis
jeff disent on va exercer kutcher ne
veut pas prendre donc il doit trouver un
autre espoir pour son fou donc là les
noirs notamment continuent leurs plans
un logis ils ont aussi un problème nord
faut le signaler quand même un
s'essouffle c8 qui a le même problème
que le fou c'est un c il est bouché donc
le camp qui arrivera à trouver la
meilleure solution pour ces fous risque
d'avoir un petit avantage pour l'instant
les noirs choisissent tranquillement de
mettre le roi à l'abri ça y est petit
rock les tours vont pouvoir bientôt
jouer entre elles
une fois que les fours en jouer donc les
blancs pendant celle un peu vite là
après le petit robe pour les noirs on
faisait beaucoup ça y est les blancs
jouent le fou sur la case b2 voilà ça y
est ce fou maintenant à une possibilité
d'action sous cette grande diagonale
puisque à tout moment ce pion ici en d4
peut s'échanger contre le pion c5 ou
être poussés ou être repoussée sur la
case des 5 est donc libéré l'action de
ce fou qui pourra avoir une action vers
le camp des noirs maintenant le
choisissent de positionner finalement
leur fou sur la case 17 au 11e coup donc
les noirs position de leurs sous sols
cos 17
on a l'impression que ce fou quand même
moins actifs potentiellement que ce fou
ici sur la classe b 2 puisqu'il a une
action potentiel très forte alors que ce
fou 17
on voit mal à moins que ce il faudrait
bouger ce cavalier ce qu'avait laissé
six faudrait que ce calibre où je mets
en voit pas trop où
afin que le fou éventuellement se met
sur la case ces six sur sept la caisse
du cavally il faut noter aussi que donc
souhaité unis et est très juste et faut
noter que justement chat chef a attendu
le dernier moment il a fait tous les
coups utile dans sa position il a
attendu le dernier moment pour jouer fou
17 ans avait d'abord il a fait le petit
rock
ils assurent toutes ces pièces il a fait
de partir le petit rock et maintenant il
est prêt pour certaines pièces
alors il n'a pas besoin de trouver une
ouverture il veut aussi simplement
mettre sa tour en jeu et puis lieu c'est
tout et c'est donc il attend
tranquillement en fait la suite des
événements pour l'instant la position je
pense est pressé imposition on peut
estimer qu'elle est à peu près égale
peut-être un petit avantage de lampes
d'agde rendu c'est fou plus actifs alors
là ça arrive peut-être envahisseurs
justement sans le moment venu d'essayer
de d'activer un petit peu les choses et
joue le coup de dé 5 voilà au deuxième
coup ça y est ils jouent le coup donc
ici du pion en d5 avec beaucoup d'idées
à la fois ils attaquent évidemment le
calice et si c'est le pion aux 6,9 alors
que les noirs réagissent très vite
probablement en prenant le pion des cinq
et il active du coup du bon coup la
grande diagonale du fou les deux là qui
se retrouvent pendant que je sais pas
pourquoi je les fasse qui se retrouve
tout de suite avoir une attaque
potentielle importante vers le roi noir
en échange de quoi si les noirs prennent
ce qui va sûrement arrivé d'ailleurs sur
la case des cinq c'est le flou 17 qui
lui va retrouver son avenir un peu mieux
un peu meilleur aussi mais peut-être
moins moins dangereux
dans un premier temps en tout cas vers
le roi blanc maintenant je vais me
rajouter ça reste très subtil c'est pas
toujours il ya toujours pas davantage
net mais on allait en effet moi c'est le
sentiment en tout cas dans cette
position que les blancs sont un tout
petit peu mieux
oui disons que ça finalement on peut se
demander pourquoi ils jouent des cinq
puis ce qui libère le fou adverse mais
bon il ya peut-être pas grand-chose donc
l'univers son propos voilà weiser aussi
a décidé bon d'aller de l'avant c'est un
joueur qui attaque donc il essaie
d'ouvrir le centre et moi les s'est
décidé à ce moment là quoi donc là les
noirs ça ils prennent le pion des cinq
au douzième coup car il prend des 5 pour
les blancs et appris que les noirs
prennent le cavalier en d5 ou 14e coup
les blancs avec vous prenez 5 donc ça
sud des changes logique un fred et 5 et
les noirs jouent le coup tu auras des
huit activation seuils de la torah 8 qui
viennent des 8 avec une action
maintenant sur la colonne encore un coup
logique hein on essaye de faire jouer
les pièces qui joue le moins une pour le
centre toutes les pistes ont développé
les pisse mineurs on a fait le rock
il faut que tu les trouves voilà on fait
tous les coups et il au fait on le fout
en dix-sept va bouger c'est sûr mais on
ne sait pas encore où donc patiemment et
jouent tous les coups et il
et après il déterminera la position du
fou 17 alors maintenant weiser trouve un
joli coup je pense qu'ils aient étant
donné qu'il est sa majorité sa fameuse
majorité centrale pour l'instant faut
pas bien que les cases du centre sont
importantes
donc ces quatre 4 centrales ici et les
blancs on le pian e4 ici je vais enlever
j'ai enlevé autre case centrale le pion
à 4 contre 0 pions pour les noirs les
purs mais n'en manque pas d'opposants à
ce niveau là donc en fait les blancs une
petit avantage centrale sauf que je
rectifie le piaui temps 43 oui voilà va
arriver très bientôt à la haye pour 15e
coup walser choisi de jouer ou coût de 4
qui à la fois fortifie sont fous en d5
est salie s'installe au centre monde par
contre ça affaiblit un petit peu la case
des 4 5 et 5 pour les noirs je crains
surtout des 4 6 904 le pion aux trois
contrôler cette cale donc en otage un
inconvénient mais avantage de pions mais
souvent ça peut être décisif un petit
ami scipion de plus
on sait pas moi je laverai dire j'aime
bien les noirs parce que la caisse des
quatre je pense est très forte et très
importante ici alors peut-être les
blancs effectivement on fait alors on
peut se dire aussi que étant donné que
les blancs avaient se fout ici en b2 qui
était déjà très bien placé le coup ici
qui viennent d'être joués e4 finalement
n'apporterait pas grand chose à ce fou
parce que s'il avait été un c'est un
sort été un coup pour libérer le fou
mais tandis qu'il est déjà en b2 ce plan
est contrôlé quand même quatre centrales
important de comme tu veux comme tu
viens de le dire jozic et la case la
case des quatre peut-être les blancs on
va mieux fait de consolider leur centre
avec des coûts de tours pour renforcer
l'attention centrale bon sinon aussi ce
qui caractérise si des positions aussi
entre l'effort joueurs c'est que souvent
il sort de l'ouverture et il n'y a pas
grand chose qu'ils ont mais bon ils
doivent entreprendre quelque chose et
contre un joueur un peu plus faible ça
marche contre d'efforts joueurs bon on
l'a d'ailleurs il a trouvé le 9 très
subtil avec tel chef aq et noir et pour
vraiment à égaliser la position et même
peut-être prendre petit à son nom alors
là les noirs jouent effectivement 15e
ku'damm c8 alors l'idée de ce coup c'est
sûrement de
d'accentuer la pression sur ses des
ménages dépensent jose en foot mais ce
n'est pas parce que la plainte lancée un
coup mystérieux ça va même si c'est un
super coup parce que le fou 17 et moins
fort que le fou des cinq d'accord donc
les blancs on joue le 4 ils ont sécurisé
donc là je sais que tu peux montrer donc
ils ont joué quatre ont sécurisé la
caisse des cinq ici cette cause des
singles à et sécurisée avec les pions
ici je veux montrer en rouge l'art dans
les possibilités des noirs est donc
maintenant tu comprends mieux que je
sais pas si le fou 17 s'échange contre
le food et 5
les noirs sont très bien donc peut-être
l'idée des noirs dans ce cas là c'est de
mettre le fou 17 sur la case e si cela
n'est pas possible avant puisque voilà
donc de mettre ce fou sur cette case ici
aussi simple que je fait clignoter
si vous voyez pour essayer de s'échanger
contre le foot des 5 1 plutôt que donc
elle lorsqu'il était pas possible aux
coudes à vendre puisque la dame est sûre
la casse c'est cette si les noirs avec
joseph huang 6 les blancs auraient
détruit la structure depuis anvers
il y aurait eu vous prend et après les
nombreux obligés de prendre du pillon ce
corps affaibli la position de l'emploi
ce que fait la position de retrait ce
que redonner une meilleure position
peut-être même gagnante tout de suite
par une subtilité pour les
pour les blancs maintenant là et s'ils
arrivent à échanger son fou 17 contre le
monde seront dix ans des 5
les noirs sont très bien donc ça au 16e
coup les blancs choisi le ku'damm
cavaliers en d2 le cavalier ici ils
venus sur la case des deux voilà donc ça
c'est sûrement une manoeuvre de
valserres il veut sûrement mettre ce
cavalier ici ceux de caïds et deux sur
le cas ces quatre probablement pour
essayer de mieux contrôler les classes
noir et c'est ce que tu es 18 jeux si
c'est le cavalier est bien dans les
avant postes c'est à dire quand il est
devant un pion et qui bloque la vence
son pion là il rayonne
c'est donc donc là j'aurais aller contre
le pion c5 en fait voilà donc l'année
mais on a l'impression quand même que
c'est pas malheureusement les tours
blanches
weisser c'est peut-être on peut tromper
là avec ce coup quatre avec cette
solution parce que les tours blanches
ici se trouve toujours dans une position
passive
contrairement la tour noire ici qui est
tout de suite dans une position beaucoup
plus active puisque la ji
potentiellement en tout cas sur le
centre donc on a le sentiment que la les
noirs ont mieux activer leur pièce que
les blancs et qui sont peu fourvoyé et
qu'on essayait de manoeuvrer un petit
peu mais avec moins 10 des stratégies
guerrières bon surtout si c'est vraiment
la deuxième partie vie pour gagner ils
doivent faire quelque chose donc je
pense qu'il peut égaliser facilement si
caen avec qu'on fait mais elles sont là
donc c'est soit la 2e la première même
porte parce que un match en deux parties
les flèches blanc avec les blancs il
faut c'est de gagner
voilà sinon on est trop en slovénie de
prendre des risques pour affaiblir sa
position et là on voit que telle ou
telle faction l'idée de jouer aux dames
c'est 8 pour échanger les foules blanc
puis une très bonne idée
alors là les noirs continuent leurs
idées avec le couffo aussi sot 16e coup
et ça y est tout de suite se fout aussi
ce menace alors je ne montre en noir ici
de s'échanger contre le foot des 5 et
donc de prendre une
un petit diem petit avantage centrale
pour les noirs au niveau du contrôle en
tout cas du centre grâce à la tour des
huit qui est déjà bien placé voilà donc
là les noirs les blancs doivent réagir
tout de suite et là on va rentrer dans
une phase tactique beaucoup possibilités
tactiques alors les pièces blanches les
dix sont bien sont bien placés puisque
elles menacent le roi n'est on peut
noter effectivement que le fougueux ici
mais tape tape ici sur les curiaces est
vraiment de coordination seuil à aucune
menace aucune coordination entre les
pièces blanches et qui permet d'attaquer
finalement il ya que ce fou qui est une
action
alors je crois qu on approche de la du
temps où on va avoir un loir où l'enjeu
téléphone un invité spécial
un invité spécial oui je sais pas si on
web donc je crois qu'on l'a au téléphone
en direct de cannes à l'eau à voilà ça y
est donc que nous avons et loire où
l'ange donc notre grand maître préférées
quitte à cannes donc à l'hôtel de cannes
est donc eloi ont commenté donc la
partie entre anatolie weiser îles
vanille slave 4 chefs qui était
demi-finale du maïs est de du master
pardon tu peux toi donc maintenant qui
est qui est acquise à cannes nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé
y compris dans tes propres prestations
puisque tu as joué le master's oui le
batteur de cannes
c'est un tournoi à élimination directe
elle groupe avec 32 joueurs invités et
les dates jeu se jouer à la cadence 50
minutes par joueur alors on attend tout
de suite ils voient peut-être on peut
montrer loi en plein écran pendant que
il est au téléphone
si c'est possible au niveau de la
réalisation de le montrer en plein écran
parce que sinon on le verra pas voilà je
préfère donc voila tu peux continuer loi
oui donc ce n'est pas ça mais nous
n'avions 32 joueurs deux partie de 50
minutes chacun en cas d'égalité des
blitz de départage et effectivement
c'est un peu exceptionnel dans les
échecs puisque on a vu dès l'égalisation
de grands maîtres tels premier tour ans
et je fais partie de ces grands maîtres
malheureux puisque j'ai eu la
désagréable surprise de jouer contre
jean-luc chavanon au premier tour qui
est un peu ma bête noire ça me fait pas
peur d'affronter qui est déjà venu dans
des malles et il n'a battu sur le score
de fanta bel20 donc éliminée dès le
premier tour et des alliés mais dans
votre vie est un haut lieu
mais c'est aussi c'est aussi ton grand
ami donc c'est à l'eau mais c'est aussi
un grand ami à toi jean-luc chavanon est
vrai que le portalet beaucoup avec lui
bon il a un fils de la crise et à milan
et adapter le score d'abord fait partie
et de fracas
avoir un des chevaux de moins dans le
monde oui alors qu'elle faisait
moi je propose d'ailleurs de recruter le
souligne nathalie modesto jean-luc
chavanon à la place des lois puisque
larry cela ne va qu'en penses tu non
mais alors donc ce masters ce comment ça
s'est déroulé dans finalement ou la f4
et f5 confirmer puisqu'il avait déjà
gagné l'année dernière
non non il avait gagné en finale ouais
il avait gagné contre son ami ou ce
constat se monte à 15 il avait affiché
un petit une petite embrouille culte que
c'était dans les petites se départageant
match très très pentu d'aller payer à
larache enfin l'arraché par guetter ce
match et cette année on l'a senti très
très petit il très à l'aise puisque ils
à leur promettre le départage seulement
pour la finale tous les matches
précédents montaiguet très simplement et
là et elle a joué contre le russe
s'achève original
après impôts retour aussi rapide il a
fait un partout au 1er mai le bit et
s'imposait 2-0 dans le deuxième mais
donc on attend pierre vladislav tkachiev
et décontracté détendu
ils ont dansé sur son terrain par la
ville de cannes donc en fait on peut
dire premiers servent qu'à kiev confirme
son excellent début d'année avec ces
matches gagnés contre alberto david et
contre van der wiel et il continue de
s'approcher des tout meilleurs mondiaux
oui effectivement sont dénoués vêtements
2670 if i à iv était le grand favori ce
tournoi bien sûr tout le monde
l'attendait on va attendre également la
prestation de nice et alou qui avait été
demi finales du championnat du monde
mais c'était sortir au thème de détour
donc évidemment une fois qu'on est sorti
on ne revient plus alors que free table
que chez lui
ces trois fautes et donc confirme
effectivement sa position dominante
quel joueur mondial et il a pas de le
retrouver donc c'est une bonne augure
pour le prochain grand prix de bordeaux
effectivement il fait partie des favoris
du grand prix de bordeaux et le tournoi
est également très relevé avec michael
adams notamment joël mottier aussi
laurent fatigué qu'il ya peu figure de
traders mais effectivement fait cette
qualité pour la temps puisqu'en semi
rapide en jeu rapide ont généralisé
pendant extrêmement alors deuxième
actualité qui s'auto déroula encore à
cannes on a parlé du train de
cappelle-la-grande donc on y reviendra
pas mais puisque tu as cannes on va
continuer de parler de ce qui se passe
là bas et il ya donc le match et entre
eux donc notre jeune star nationale qui
est numéro 2 français et qui a donc tout
jeune à 16 ans etienne bacrot qu'ils
rencontrent donc là la grande star
mondiale
alain tony karpov donc ça c'est un match
excellent oui elle affiche d'ailleurs à
cannes fillon on ne jure que par se
battre je lui ai vraiment l'événement
l'événement qui fait la une de toute la
presse qu'à droite toute l'afrique du
sud et tout le palais des festivals tout
le festival international des jeux est
vraiment sous le soul augure de ce match
et qui a de gros contrats noter le
carton donc bon les joueurs évidemment
ne les présente plus un atelier art of
chantre du groupe en europe les dix ans
et quelques accrochages entre 300 titres
que je ne remets de tous les tons et si
la particularité de ce match c'est que
c'est dans trois cas dans c'est à dire
que les joueurs vivront de parking puis
2000 rapide et enfin 2 lite pour finir
et là on est à la pause ce vendredi
puisque et ont fini les deux parties
longues et etienne a tenu le choc
il a fait un exploit on peut dire qu'il
a réussi à tenir la police à paul en
faisant deux parties nulles très très
solide donc c'est un match c'est hamas
qui promet mais alors d'après les
commentaires même deux
2 etienne bacrot
il espérait pouvoir prendre l'aventage
dans les parties lentes parce qu'il a
l'impression que karpov et plus fort en
blitz et notamment et en partie rapide
en particulier n'en est pas tout à fait
puisque effectivement on compte un
atelier karpov
c'est partit des meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux il l'a récemment prouvé aux
championnats du monde de beach où il est
dominée tournant il était en tête tout
le temps avant de craquer sur la fin
mais en finir rapide 7 à moitié vrai
puisque il a quand même perdu un bâton
puis dit paul hier sur un score assez
sévère a vu la bête je crois que je vais
y était et en semi rapide avec le
diplôme n'est pas tout à fait par contre
en blitz
ça va être très très dur pour etienne
donc là je pense bon un partout c'est
quand même un très bon score en partie
donc il faut pas non plus oublier qu'à
pop lady déploiement des halles 11e que
fait que c'est un monument des échecs
tueur c'est vraiment un joueur très très
fort et réussir à faire deux nuls contre
anatoli karpov à ton âge est viré enfin
en l'état des choses c'est quand même
exceptionnel d'accord donc pour
l'instant donc positif pour etienne
bacrot on peut dire qu'il a donc réussi
pour l'instant son défi il n'y reste
donc à confirmer dans les parages
peut-être donc les parties rapides c'est
le moment où pour lui d'essayer de
prendre l'avantagé
oui voilà effectivement c'est là que je
verrais bien ils viennent faire la vraie
surprise c'est à dire réécrira tobin et
anatoli karpov puisqu'on sait que karpov
s'est raté mal content merci
eto'o se retrouver des valeurs très très
violent avec un beau coup à jouer en
très peu de temps qui n'est pas du tout
une bonne chose ang lee par contre mes
anatoli karpov tard la voilà donc
malheureusement on ne peut pas
retransmettre ce match en direct pour
des raisons d'exclusivité mais c'est pas
grave on retransmettra le grand prix de
bordeaux en direct
donc on se rattrapera là dessus et en
attendant mais on espère quand même que
les tiennent évidemment va réussir à au
moins de tenir le choc contre le contre
anatoli karpov donc eloi je pense que tu
as passé ta passé un très bon moment à
cannes malgré son élimination et que tu
as pu suivre tous les parcours des baies
de tes collègues grand maître donc à la
fois donc dans le masters savez la
victoire de quatre chefs et puis
actuellement avec ce match entre etienne
macro et anatoli karpov et que tu donc
connu une vague nous rejoignent dans la
semaine prochaine oui exactement alors
effectivement à cannes c'est vrai qu'on
voit tous les jours des chefs dans un
autre milieu en fait sont vraiment tous
très très joueurs et au festival et j'en
ai l'occasion de voir plusieurs temps
comptera pas pour la pelote et ainsi de
suite
le spectacle chacun est largement à la
hauteur de ce qu'on attendait et je
reviendrai vous voir la prochaine dans
la porte oui josé je vois que vous
l'avez pas une question c'est est-ce que
le master's et populaire disons ce que
tu parlais du match mais est-ce que ça
intéresse les gens c'est faux cette
formule le coupe en semi rapide d'un
public
y a pas de public autre que les joueurs
d'échecs qui viennent pour l'amateur
puisque c'est sombre affaire de
communication je dirais on n'a pas fait
fait par les toits tournoi en revanche
là mon ami le pape y était pour le match
pas trop carter et là effectivement la
salle est pleine le grand grand
auditorium de calais voilà soir en petit
et donc ça prouve que la formule des
gets rapide et est tout à fait
attrayante pour le pour le public
voilà mais on te remercie et loi et donc
on te donne rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine voilà donc on va revenir
maintenant donc après ses commentaires
des lois aux langes en direct de cannes
sur donc cette partie entre anatolie
weiser et vladislav tkachiev donc on
était donc au 16e coup les noirs avaient
joué le coup fou un e 6 et au dix
septième coup les noirs les blancs
jouent le coup cavaliers en c4 alors là
ça y est on va rentrer jeu
on n'est pas dans une position qui va
être compliqué oui c'est vrai parce que
il ya les petites combines en fait il
dépité astuces qui font que les blancs
tiennent la position alors tout de suite
on va voir une première astuce c'est que
si les noirs prennent des cinq ici les
blancs reprendre y avait le pion de d4
et si les noirs davanture s'avérait
enfin essayer de reprendre le pian il y
aurait une astuce final on peut la cité
tout de suite posé une petite fourchette
comme on dit dans les échecs
voilà lecavalier 6 4 ici pardon viendrai
sur la case des six attaquants la table
et attaquant la tour qui aurait repris
le pion voilà c'est un peu compliqué
mais ça montre que le pif ou des seuils
n'est pas tout à fait prenable pour
l'instant et on le reverra dans une
manière un peu un peu plus simplifié
plus tard cette même combinaison cette
même fourchette va revenir donc ceux qui
on peut bien compris vont pouvoir
apprécier alors la lester technique ce
geste de techniques de taper alors là
les noms a choisi ce maintenant
d'envahir eux mêmes le camp des blancs
avec le coup puisque le cours n'a vidic
le coup et quatre des blancs le coup de
pied on affaiblit c'est cette fameuse
cadets 4 et nord en veille cette case
des quatre attaquants tout de suite la
dame
ce qui crée des problèmes pour les pour
les blancs puisque en plus le pion b3
est attaqué et si je me montre ici voilà
le pion b3 is it attaqué aussi par le
cavalier difficile à défendre simplement
les blancs choisissent finalement de
prendre ce cavalier avec le fou par
contre bon mais il donne un fou contre
cavaliers ce qui peut s'avérer
délicat un certain moment bon disons que
là comme les fouilles vont s'échanger on
dit souvent que de fou son supérieur un
fou plus un cavalier puisqu'il domine
plus de cases ils ont ils ont une portée
plus longue mais maintenant il y à au
moins un autre fou qui va s'échanger
donc ça pas trop problème mais donc fou
contre cavale et ça peut plus facilement
égale coin mais disons que là surtout
les noirs ou éliminer un fou qui
dominait une très belle diagonale
donc je peux montrer le débat n'a là on
l'a déjà vu souvent les m17 fermeté le
canal ici qu'on disait que ça tapait sur
le pion jessel ça y est ils sont là ils
risquent hélas il une position je pense
qu'il peut être égale légèrement
supérieure pour les noirs je préférais
je préfère quand même
voilà donc les normands 18e coup
finalement reprennent le pion normal et
là ça y est les blanches se décide
finalement à activer leur tour ce qu'ils
auraient pu faire avant mais qu'ils ont
décidé de différer un temps d'en essayer
va au 7e tour prend donc de l'action et
potentiellement peut menacer la dame
noire adverse alors les noirs
choisissent maintenant de prendre en d5
c'était de reggae stratégie deuxième
coup c'était laurier stratégique on me
dit tout à l'heure vous prendre les 5
puis on prend des 5es attention pour les
noirs il faut surtout pas que la tour
prennent le pionner 5 parce que le
cavaly viendrait sur la case b6 ici
attaquant la dame ans et 8 et la tour en
d5
voilà donc ce serait ça serait une
grosse erreur puisque les blondes
gagneraient ce qu'on appelle la qualité
il resterait donc avec une tour contre
une piste mineurs dont karine avantage
conséquent aucun cas un joueur de ce
talent concrétise assez facilement voilà
c'est parce que bon c'est vrai c'est
toujours difficile avait-il donc les
noirs finalement le joug de coûts
cavaliers d'amendé sept
voilà donc la ici la noix la dame est
venue sur place 17 c'est la menace mais
tente de prendre le pion dd5 est réel
puisqu'il ya plus de fourchette et la
maintenance
donc là les blancs choisissent
effectivement de jouer quand même le
cavalier sur la case b6 ça attaque la
dame est évidemment mais surtout ça
protège le plan des cinq donc c'est un
coup efficacement mais c'est alors le
cavalier imbéciles se parait bien mais
il est quand même isolé du centre et ça
ça serait une remarque il faut il faut
faire c'est à dire est bon il va être
bien placé on va voir même être
sécurisés en b 6 mais il est loin du
centre et il va avoir du mal à revenir
par exemple voilà pas activé voilà
peut-être le problème c'est que cette
position a l'air bien pour les blancs
mais les noirs ont eux aussi un pion
central maintenant on se plante des 5
des cas pardon contre le pion des 5 pour
les blancs et finalement le fou ici en
recette va peut-être s'avérer plus
actifs alors peut-être en venant sur
cette case
il aura une action beaucoup plus à petit
vers le roi alors que ce cas allez va
être obligé de rester sur la classe b 6
pour continuer à protéger soutient donc
malgré que
il a l'air efficace il peut s'avérer
finalement moins fort que le fou alors
oui donc là les noirs dire plus
voilà les noirs jouent l'agglo 21e coup
le coût d'un des six attaquants du même
coup le cavalier montré un rouge pour
les noirs voilà ce cavalier est attaqué
donc il faut absolument que les blancs
réagissent il faut surtout pas perdre en
plus le pion des 5
ces deux pièces sont attaqués donc les
blancs jouent le coup au coup suivant
joue le coup à cinq qui donc sécurisé
qu'on utilisait j'osais lecavalier et
qui donc garde le contrôle du pion des 5
de façon indirecte
donc là maintenant les noirs jouent le
couffo et fils qui eux mêmes ils
sécurisent avec ce fou ici ils
sécurisent leurs propres pions des
quatre donc les blanc et noir finalement
deux pions centre au passé puisque les
deux peuvent pousser la dame a priori il
n'y a pas de pions adverse
demain malheureusement tous les deux il
faut les protéger il faut les protéger
par contre c'est le fou qui protège pour
les noirs et le cavalier qui protège
poule et blanc alors si lecavalier bouge
le pion est perdu par contre si le
football il peut encore dans des cases
intéressante surtout que là donc le
cavalier est un peu isolé mais le fou et
si ce n'est pas mieux loti disons de
manière générale puisque il est
contraint par son propre pions non moi
il est bouchée par seconde avec sa
diagonale le montre bien il est embauché
par son concurrent donc il faut mettre
pour les blancs les pions sur la case du
fou pour contraindre son action et on va
le voir ce que j'essaie de faire visible
donc 23 dame c4 on va être obligé de
l'intérieur accéléré puisque la position
est fixé un josé pour arriver à la
position qui va être crucial les noirs
activent leurs coûts leur tour au 23e
coup tu aurais fait huit séries toutes
les toutes les pièces sont en action
finalement les bleus en choisissent avec
le coup j'ai 3 2 mais l'idée de ce coup
tout simplement sa demande à la fois ça
donne de l'air au roi et puis ça
contrôle très bien toutes les cases
noires donc ses limites élections du
food
voilà ça limite l'action des coûts du
foner mai mais ça affaiblit la position
de son propre
voilà ça donne un sens à des cibles
parce que cette structure j'ai trois
enfants et un petit peu avancé me
ça peut être une cible d'attaqués et en
fait ça fait quatre chefs l'a très bien
compris et ils jouent le coup à 5
voilà c'est un jour de la nouvelle école
mais dès qu'ils voient le roi a faibli
hop ils attaquent
voilà l'idée c'est de venir ici est
d'essayer de commencé à casser la
défense du roi blanc mais sachant qu'en
fait le fou noir ici continue à protéger
le roi noir alors que le cavalier blanc
ici est coincé il est très loin de
l'action est très loin de l'action c'est
ce qu'on disait donc y avoir du temps à
revenir et donc la valsière choisi
d'essayer d'activer son à son potentiel
réel dames puisque le cavalier se
trouvant les dames il un petit avantage
à la dame
donc il joue le coût des quatre au 25e
coup et la b4 chef continue son idée il
veut affaiblir absolument se croient
avec le courage quatre passeurs mais son
roi sur une case de la couleur inverse
du fou du roi de perse c'est ça l'idée
exactement avec le couple âgé de 25 ou
25 pour les noirs c'est les noirs essayé
d'activer maintenant leurs pièces ils
vont aussi finalement les noirs de
ramener leurs pièces vers le roi le plan
des noirs dans cette position c'est de
mettre leurs pièces contre le roi blanc
alors que le plan des billes en
maintenant que leurs cavaliers loin de
leurs droits c'est plutôt d'essayer
d'activé de du côté de la halle dame
exactement mais là tu peux mentionner
qu'il va y avoir la dame en eux cinq le
fou en f6 alors la dame on est cinq
dames 1 5 le fouloir 6 les deux tours
les deux tours et le pion h4 qui vont
attaquer le roi blanc et malheureusement
mais les blancs voient bien qu'il en
manque une pièce il manque le café libé
6 voilà il faut être cavaliers ici si ce
cavalier était en f3 ça serait beaucoup
mieux
mais cette quasi si les deux sécurisant
10 emplois seraient plus sécurisant et
déjà les noirs n'aurait pas pu jouer le
coup le coup h4 alors voilà je suis
tombé la souris le fait
voilà donc on va voir la suite des coups
donc dam des trois ans 27e ou pour les
blancs il essaie de ramener leur pièce
en défense et noire continue de menacer
leur pièce en attaque avec le coup ici
damage 5
cette dame ici pour les noirs sai et
commence à voir une action la menace
peut être déjà de pousser le plus grand
ici sur le cadastre en faisant un échec
et en créant des menaces potentielles
pour les blancs réduire
la boîte des des blancs donc tout reste
le même pour les bleus henry laissé
d'activer sa vie active leur dernière
pièce aussi sa vie cette tour finit par
avoir une action cette tour on a déjà
une ils essaient d'activer leurs pièces
le problème c'est toujours ce cavalier
ici en sur la case b6 pardon ici qui est
toujours un peu à l'extérieur malgré qui
fait rien de particulier à port défendre
évidemment le pion sur la caisse des 5
c'était un but noble point une position
de pas si vous le donne en exemple ici
anticipe donc là les noirs choisissent
de faire le coup h3 avec échec au 28e
coup mais avantage c'est que après le
court en f1 la case g2 ici pour les
blancs est très faible
c'est vers l'est contrôlé par le pion h3
et si la dame davanture venait à se
poster par exemple via las casas 3 vice
3 pardon sur la case g2 ça pourrait être
faire un match tout simplement
donc il faut faire très attention
maintenant aux cases blanches pour les
possibles niveau ligne c'est une épine
dont le petit vers 10hoo voilà il et les
titille il a titillé petit peu les noirs
maintenant on va la jouer le coup ici
tour sur la case de 5 avec l'idée de
doubler les tours doublé tout est de
jouer toujours trop après donc jouer un
jeep et au sacrifice de divination dit
voilà un coup tour trois attaquants la
dame
et si le pion ici f3 venez apprendre la
dame h5 viendrait sur la case f3 avec un
échec mortelle il y aurait un impact
rapide
il ouvre le roi est donc bon signe tout
de suite quand il faut faire attention à
cette ce type de menace donc c'est pour
ça que les blancs jouent le coup f4 pour
ce qui est de ramener cette tour vers
l'extérieur et donner de l'air au roi un
donne un peu d'air aux un jour de suite
donc là les noirs jouent le coup de
tours 7
les blancs et c2d d'extirper le revois
démentiel voilà il c'est de prendre un
peu d'air avec leur or white 2 et au 30e
coup les noirs prennent la tour sur la
case eu un lait blanc reprennent sur la
case 1 et ensuite le coup dames
angers 4 donc qu'elle peut être une idée
de ce que josé cette démarche
s'inscrivait sur le casse g4 elle a une
option évidemment sur cette diagonale
mais sinon
elle a perdu son action sur la traverse
ici quel peut être son utilité disons
maintenant les noirs en fait ils doivent
ramener des munitions pour attaquer et
donc le but c'est un peu de pousser le
cuir j 5
alors l'idée pour les noirs donc je vais
enlever les flèches ici voilà l'idée
pour les noirs maintient ses positions
de ramener des mini celle de jouer le
coup j'ai sept g5 si la dame avait était
resté sur cette case h5 peut-être les
blancs on aurait pu jouer la dame
eux-mêmes sur la case f5 pour essayer de
contrecarrer l'action noir il sort était
très efficace
alors qu'ici la dame g4 contrôler cette
case et petites cases f5 donc c'est
beaucoup plus efficace pour ensuite et
en plus il ya une menace directe sur f4
quand il jouait f5
quand ils joueront g5 pardon il ya un
menace directe sur f4 puisque la dame
gkd attaquera f4 et le pion g5
on va le voir tout de suite on va le
voir tout de suite alors là maintenant
les noirs jouent le coup des six a alors
avec l'idée toute simple toute simple
c'est que si les noirs prennent le pion
tout simplement ignoré tour sur la case
échec et mat puisque la case h7 est
contrôlé par la dame voyage eux-mêmes
toutes les cases que de contrôler dadame
donc y aurait un match le match du cool
ou un match donc en général va du
couloir 6 mais les trois pions mais la
dame fait office de remplacement du
curage cette idée si c'est un très beau
coup parce que ça mais en fait en marche
son pion passé et ça donne un peu un
rôle aux cavaliers b61 voit donc là les
noirs réagi tout de suite avec le koup
g5 et il crée une menace tout de suite
faire le roi blanc
ils menacent de prendre en f4 et de
détruire complètement laurent par
durable en il se donne un peu d'air
aussi les noirs parce que maintenant il
ya plus de maîtres du couloir alors
peut-être là les blancs auraient eu
intérêt peut-être à ce moment là haut
donc au 34e coup de jouer le coup dès 6
ans 17 mon à 100 peut-être tour 8 avec
matt c'est le bon coup c'est le bon coup
on a l'impression que c'est un coût
efficace mon bon maintenant les bombes
le mans jouera g7 - y'a rien de spécial
pour les blancs mais c'est un bon coup
qui donne une capuche
donne un bon coup fait qu'il donne une
utilité aux cavaliers et b6 et qui
empêche la tour noire de bouger ce plan
mais cette menace et moi je pense que ça
aurait été un très beau coup mais la
valise a choisi de réactiver son
cavalier avec le coup cavaliers en d5
menace cavalli prend m6 je veux montrer
en blanc pendant quarante-six échec au
roi et je vais pas y arriver parce que
je veux que mon train blanc et hop
fourchette en prendrait la dame non dits
fourchette royal fonctionne exactement
donc là les blancs les noirs prennent le
pion des death is hell avantage c'est
comme prendre un champion on contrôle le
fou donc il ya plus de fourchette royal
les blancs et c'est quand même de
prendre évidemment d'échangé soumis
élimine un fou d'attac
voilà ton problème 6 maintenant les
blancs récupère le pion des quatre mails
à quatre chefs a trouvé la solution
1 les blancs attaque la tour f 6 mai les
noms vont réussir à regrouper leurs
forces tout en le corsaire conservant
par dont le potentiel de leur attaque
ici sur le coin f4 avec le coup très
simple dames f5
voilà ça protège je vais y arriver en
rouge voilà ça protège le pur et fils
est aussi sans ça attaque le roi le pion
f4 ne peut plus bouger les clous et et
il est sous le feu du pion g5
c'est très difficile notamment pour les
blancs mais moi je devrais te contredire
un peu là on va voir le coup suivant des
blancs donc si tu peux avancer au coup
suivant des blancs tours secs et bien
maintenant avec le coup tours 5
les blancs quand même contrôler toutes
les cases centrale et ils peuvent pas
être moins bien je pense à dire on a
l'illusion que les noirs
samson sont mieux parce que bon et le
roi et blanc est très faible mais
maintenant le roi noir n'est pas mieux
loti et toutes les pièces blanches sont
au centre et regan assez bien en tout
cas la menace pour les blancs c'est que
si la dame par par exemple ici cette
dame si elle part sur la case ses 8
c'est tout simplement cette touriste y
soient vus prendre et le plus engagé 5
avec un échec au roi et ça sera un gros
avantage blanche cette fois donc tu veux
montrer aussi que la dame est en d4 et
l'ademe un rayonnement sa demi siècle
rayonnement fantastique puisque le
contrôle nombre de cases important
important donc les blancs ne sont pas
moins bien je pense disons que ça suffit
pour faire nul avec les noirs parce que
bon il ya des le roi blanc est mal en
point mais c'est pas gagné
alors la quatrième fois calculer ça
évidemment et joue le coup dams et deux
avec échec alors là on peut se demander
les noirs les blancs ont par contre par
dont on aurait pu y jouer le coup tour
sur la case eu deux appareils cet échec
c'est le meilleur coup je pense que
c'était plus ou moins égales disons les
pièces blanches sont bien placés quoi
être surtout la tour et la dame en plus
quand on enlève la tour de on menaçait
tours 6 il ya en effet deux rayons x sur
la reste que quatre chefs
éventuellement on fait une erreur ah non
tu achèteras pas fait d'erreur je pense
que c'est c'est égal disons mais il faut
qu'ils gagnent mais vas y tire tout
gagné donc ils essayent peut-être
d'aller de l'avant et
et là il fait une faute l'afutt il fait
la faute avec le coût 38 roi f3 et elle
a sanctionné immédiatement par quatre
chefs avec jeu avec la suite
donc il a été un peu gourmand il a fait
tilt il a cru qu'il était mieux parce
qu'il avait tout la position centrale
donc il a monté son droit mais très joli
coup très belle combinaison finale qui
gagne pour les noirs d'alger deux
chèques aux 38e coup les blancs jouent
le sol à la case g4 orages et 4 et la
coupe gagnant pour les noirs tout
reprend f4 superbe sur scène ils peur
voilà sortis de nulle part un petit peu
tous points f4 avec échec et donc échec
pendant sur le roi noir et la dame
blanche est attaqué on peut remarquer
que les blancs ne peuvent pas apprendre
en f4 à cause de la dame en g2 ici qui
cloue qui tout le pion g3 donc la perte
des pour les blancs après d'un point f4
puis on prend un f4 les blancs les noirs
en gagner une dame contre une tour à ce
niveau du jeu il ya plus de matches une
dame est beaucoup plus forte qu'une tour
surtout que fait la dame va prendre tous
les tubes qui restent et et faire
d'autres dames sans problème alors que
la tour aura beaucoup de mal à résister
il ya plus de il ya plus de possibilités
c'est une superbe victoire de quatre
chefs aux nerfs on peut dire puisque la
partie 8 et non finalement de très
tendue oui et puis en fait ça devait
être comme ces 58 contre 50 minutes
c'est comme un jeu rapide
à la fin il dit avoir un peu d avec
notes et puis un peu d'énervement et et
puis walser s'est un peu énervé ça
craint un peu curieux que valises et
remonte son droit parce qu'on sait que
dame tour contre dame tour celui qui est
le roi le plus exposé père on peut dire
que ça s'est par contre c'est le type de
match que ce qu'il est agréable de
suivre en direct et commenté en direct
parce que là on sait pas ce qui va se
passer
et là on voit qu'il ya des retournements
on sait plus trop qui al'avantage nous
mais on a du mal à voir puisque on a
bien vu qu'ils avaient peut-être
davantage pour les noirs mais finalement
le dernier coup blanc était peut-être
bon fait un bond donc on voit que c'est
il ya des retournements de situations
très fort donc la tension psychologique
est à son maximum
il ya en plus les parties de ce niveau
là sont toujours des parties tendu c'est
un des grands mecs sont très fort hills
est toujours de jouer la tension pour
essayer de gagner et donc ça fait de
belles parties surtout quand weiser
ichaïev ces deux joueurs nerveux 10 ont
en tout cas voilà 19 4 7 qui gagne un
master de cannes voilà la nouvelle de
cette semaine avec le match bacrot
karpov qui n'est pas encore terminée
linares qui démarre le 28 février donc
très bientôt donc s'arrête le super
tournoi de l'année le plus grand tournoi
de l'année le wimbledon des échecs donc
on commence à la semaine prochaine et
rendez vous donc pour une nouvelle
émission diagonale vendée prochain mon
sweat shirt